hello and welcome to PhD watch this is
the series where I'll be talking about
my PhD in theoretical atmospheric
physics at the University of Exeter and
in this first episode I'm going to talk
about the fact that oh god everything's
changed we've seen some dramatic scenes
I say we I mean I in my PhD recently
here's actual footage when the inside of
my PhD is showing what it's been like
you have to think of the PhD as being
like your supervisors telling you where
to go say your supervisor has told you
to go to Hawaii and I'm in the UK and
you talk to you supervisor you go okay
well why don't you just go over the top
of Canada and you go through the ice
there and then you go round and down see
if guys agree yeah that makes sense okay
and then go on go off so you do that and
then you run into the ice and you get
stuck and you realise that the ice is a
lot harder than you thought it was and
your [ __ ] maybe isn't quite as strong as
you thought it was you keep plugging
away and plugging away plugging away and
then eventually a second supervisor
comes out two on deck and goes what are
you doing why are you just go for this
canal like you know in the middle of the
Americas and then just go along through
and you go why you didn't my supervisor
tell me that in the first place now
that's that's simplifying it and I'm
being mean to my first supervisor that's
not how it happened but basically I'm
still going to the same destination I'm
still researching the same topic which
is stratosphere troposphere coupling and
explaining how events in the middle
atmosphere affect weather at the surface
it's just that I'm now pursuing it very
different route and a route that is more
aligned with the mainstream of what
other people are doing in the field
basically what we're proposing in the
first place is a new index a new way of
looking at the problem and in order to
get to that new way of looking at the
problem we were also using a technique
that was new
basically my second supervisor said no
that's that's that's crazy either people
use this technique for a reason the
mainstream uses this other technique for
a reason so just do that and then use
that to get to any result now this
represents a huge change and it means
that in effect everything that I've done
over the past sort of a year and a half
isn't gonna go into my thesis but what
it has taught me is how to do the work
I'm going to do so much faster so I
learned to code in Python for example
and that's now the language that I'm
coding
my my code and now it's taught me
several analytical skills it's taught me
how to approach a problem come up with
an idea test the idea and then move
forward so I am not at all worried about
the fact that I'm a large part of my PhD
isn't going into my thesis in fact
there's a saying at least amongst quite
a few people here which is that the PhD
is like three years of training to spend
six months doing a PhD I'm curious by
the way if you're a PhD student who's
watching this first of all hi comment
below if you think that's like an
experience for you I'm really being a
PhD student can be kind of an isolation
quite an isolating experience mean yes
there's a community small community of
PhDs in your field at your university
but it's that's under one set of
circumstances it's it's not across the
board and I'm always interested to hear
from the PhD students so you know say hi
so this change in course that's gone has
basically required me to overhaul
everything I've done but obviously for
and everything I've done up until this
point out the window and I've started
fresh over the past month I think I
probably bit in about one and a half to
two thousand lines of code of which are
half which I had throw away again and
starting again basically I'm looking at
a problem called PV inversion and I
tried one mathematical technique and I
did it according to the postdoc in the
office with me exactly right I'm just
limited by the limitations of the
hardware and the language so with a huge
amount of inspiration from him and he
sent me some notes over what he's done
in the past I nosing a different
technique which is if you're interested
it's called successive over relaxation
and that's actually now working in fact
I got back home from the office today
despite the fact that this is Sunday and
in the middle of the Easter weekend and
it's now actually producing some
sensible results now I just need to test
that and hopefully you know that's
that's you know Regas step forward to my
thesis and presenting my work in Vienna
which is another deadline that's coming
up in about 23 days I think it is I'm
gonna be presenting my work on a big
stage in Vienna in front of the world's
experts on stratosphere troposphere
coupling and we already I know I'm gonna
be presenting the idea I just want to
have some data that I've generated to go
with it it's a really ambitious goal but
if you don't set yourself ambitious
goals you don't accomplish things that
are considered ambitious so now I'm
doing dedicated videos about my PhD I
can go into a bit more depth on
this so I'm gonna talk about what P V
inversion actually is you guys have
often asked me to talk about more depth
and research so you asked for it so P V
is a composite variable it's a it's a
quantity in the atmosphere that
represents the combination of your
momentum equation so basically what the
winds doing what the temperatures doing
and what the vertical profile on the
atmosphere it looks like and the analogy
that I've been thinking recently is
imagine that you're looking at a
football pitch there's a football game
going on you freeze the frame and you
you have the distribution of players
over the over the field you know you
have a set domain that you're looking at
which is the football pitch you have the
players and they have the ball now
imagine if I took this picture and I
erase the ball from the distribution of
the players you can infer where the ball
is if people are turning towards those
people looking at one point or if
there's a guy running and loads of
people are following him you know that
he has the ball so the players determine
where the ball is you can think of it
that way now in the atmosphere this
would be like saying that the ball is
your potential vorticity your PV and the
players positions are the wind but you
can look at it from the other way
if I arrays all the players and keep the
ball can i from just the position of the
ball in the football pitch determine
where the players are and to first order
know you'd need to know other bits of
information so say that you knew what
formation is the team were playing and
say that one was playing in four four
two and one was playing in three five
two given that and the distribution of
the ball you could get a pretty good
guess about where each player is it's
not any perfect but you're gonna get a
pretty decent guess and that is the
problem of PV inversion that's the
problem of saying I know what the PV
distribution is what's the wind doing so
you have this quantity that has lots of
information bound up in it the position
of the ball and you're trying to
extrapolate that well not extrapolate
we're trying to from that invert that
information and give you the position of
all the players that's the problem I'm
looking at and if that sounds
complicated it's because it is so the
particular problem I am looking at is
given our PV distribution not what I'm
not interesting what the winds doing
quite I'm interested in what the wind
times another variable is I don't to go
into too much detail but it's basically
it's it's the wind time something else
which you also get from the PV and I
need that to a quite high level of
precision I need it through the internet
for the whole atmosphere from the
surface - well we're capping it at about
the upper stratosphere beyond that point
now mist so thin that it we don't need
to really consider it once I have that
code up and running that can take a
given PV distribution and translate that
into this quantity which for interested
in then we're talking that is then a
piece of code which I'm gonna row again
again and again in my thesis and in what
I'm going to be presenting in Vienna so
it has to be right and it has to be
accurate and quick at the moment it is
now working the first requirement is the
code being right and that it runs is is
ticked now I need to test that it's
actually correct you know that is that
is accurate
once that's down it's actually pretty
fast I don't need to really worry about
the last bit once that's down then I'm
good to be spending
are you seriously considering of
sleeping back into the office because
I'm probably gonna spend I think godly
amount of time getting results out if we
can get this code working in time to put
into my plots to talk of Vienna and then
as well as that at Vienna as well as the
actual science stuff I've been invited
to talk on two panels so I'm going to be
talking on a panel about social media
and using social media to broadcast
science communications talking about
this kind of thing talking about my
Twitter recently my Instagram I am at
Simon octopus on both of those if you
haven't followed me why and then as well
as the social media one I'm also gonna
be on a panel about filmmaking so this
exactly which I'm really really excited
to do I actually went to a panel on
filmmaking two years ago and my
knowledge in filmmaking has come along a
long long way since then so I'm excited
to actually kind of give back as it were
because I learned a lot in that and then
sort of try to take it further and
further by just making videos that's
that's how you get good at video making
if you're looking for a tip is to make
videos your first 50 are terrible but
then after that you start to get kind of
a right I think that's probably not to
be getting on with for one video if you
like the format of me just talking about
my research if you're a PhD file then
comment below if you're a PhD student
yourself please please say hi and
link to your Twitter or whatever and
I'll follow you really looking forward
to meeting some of you guys and if
you're going to 8eg you actually comment
below because you know maybe we could
all come out if there's loads of people
we'd love to organize a meet-up and we
can all meet each other IRL
and if you guys would like to hear more
about PV and how you go about inverting
it and maybe actually looking at the
maths I'm thinking of doing the video on
that if you'd like to see that again
comment below it seems like what I do in
these videos is tell you the comments so
you can do what you want but I you know
if you'd like to comment that would help
me and yeah I can make that for you
which I'd be quite keen on doing
personally thanks for watching if you
like this I'll do more and if you're a
researcher be the code D bugs be ever in
your favor
data indicates the average Westerner in
its 10 tonnes of co2 per year two and a
half tonnes of widget comes from that
food